Nos piden resolver y graficar
un sistema de ecuaciones.
Y a manera de repaso, recordemos que resolver
un sistema de ecuaciones implica encontrar
los valores de "x" y "y"
que cumplen con ambas ecuaciones.
Una manera de hacer esto es despejar una de
las variables en una de las ecuaciones
y lo que se obtenga sustituirlo en la otra ecuación,
de esta manera garantizamos que estamos cumpliendo
ambas restricciones,
usemos la ecuación de abajo.
"y" menos "x" es igual a 5 y es directo despejar
una de las variables, vamos a despejar "y",
para eso sumamos "x" a ambos lados de la ecuación,
nos queda del lado izquierdo
estos términos se van y nos queda tan solo
"y" que es igual a 5 más "x",
"y" es igual a 5 más "x".
Ahora, hemos despejado "y" para que donde
aparece "y" en la otra ecuación,
sustituimos 5 más "x".
Ahora, la otra ecuación es...
la voy a poner aquí en naranja,
"9x" más "3y" es igual a 15.
Cuando despejamos "y" de la segunda ecuación,
encontramos que "y" es igual a 5 más "x",
así es que podemos sustituir "y" de la segunda
ecuación con 5 más "x", de esa manera garantizamos
que estamos cumpliendo
con ambas restricciones,
hagamos eso,
en vez de "y" sustituyamos 5más "x".
Entonces esta ecuación resulta en "9x" más 3,
en vez de "y"voy a sustituir 5 más "x",
es decir, 3 que multiplica a 5 más "x"
y esto es igual a 15.
Resolviendo ahora para "x" esta ecuación,
tenemos "9x" más 3 por 5 = 15,
más 3 por "x", "3x",
esto es igual a 15,
voy a agrupar los términos en
"x" del lado izquierdo,
que son "9x" más "3x"
es "12x" más 15,
"12x" más 15 es igual a 15,
vamos a despejar a "x" restando -15 a ambos lados... voy a restar 15 a ambos lados,
entonces,
¿qué nos queda?
Estos se cancelan y nos queda del lado izquierdo
tan solo "12x" que es igual a 0,
dividiendo entre 12 ambos lados, esto se cancela y nos
queda que "x" es igual a 0,
déjame bajar un poco,
"x" es igual a 0.
Si "x" es igual a 0,
¿cuánto vale "y"?
Podemos sustituir en cualquiera de las dos
ecuaciones que tenemos acá arriba,
sustituyendo "x" igual a 0 en la primera ecuación,
¿qué nos resulta?
9 por 0 más 3 por "y" es igual a 15.
9 por 0 es 0
y nos queda tan solo "3y" igual a 15,
dividiendo entre 3 ambos lados,
nos queda...
estos términos se van y nos queda, del lado izquierdo "y" y del lado derecho 15 entre 3 que es igual a 5,
"y" igual a 5,
podemos ver que también cumple con esta ecuación,
5 menos 0 es igual a 5.
Así es que los valores...
lo voy a hacer en verde...
los valores "x" igual a 0 y "y" igual a 5,
cumplen con ambas ecuaciones.
Así que ya hemos hecho la primera parte.
Hagamos la segunda parte.
Grafiquemos.
La segunda ecuación
se puede graficar de inmediato,
de hecho ya está en su forma
"y" igual a "mx" más "b",
de hecho, no exactamente,
déjame intercambiar "x" con 5,
para que quede en su forma "y" igual a "mx" más "b",
esto sería entonces "y" igual a "x" más 5.
La ordenada al origen es 5...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
y la pendiente es 1,
aquí está implícitamente un 1,
está multiplicado por 1 la "x",
así que la pendiente es 1.
La recta sería más o menos así...
déjame ver que tan bien me sale...
aquí sería esta recta...
si avanzas a la derecha 1, subes 1,
si avanzas a la izquierda 1,
bajas 1.
No está tan mal mi recta, así es que esa
recta corresponde a esta ecuación,
ahora grafiquemos la ecuación de arriba.
Primero llevo la ecuación a su forma "y"
igual a "mx" más "b", su forma pendiente-ordenada...
la voy a reescribir en verde...
"9x" más "3y" igual a 15,
notamos que los 3 términos
son múltiplos de 3,
así es que vamos a facilitar las cosas
dividiendo entre 3 la ecuación.
Dividimos entre 3 cada uno de estos términos
y nos queda, "3x" más "y" es igual a 5.
Ahora, restando "3x" a ambos lados...
restamos "3x" a ambos lados,
¿y qué nos queda?
Nos queda "y" es igual a "-3x" más 5,
hemos transformado la primera ecuación
a su forma pendiente-ordenada,
"y" igual a "-3x" más 5.
Vamos a graficarla.
La ordenada al origen es 5, ahí la tenemos,
y la pendiente es -3,
si te mueves 1 a la derecha bajas 3,
si te mueves 2 a la derecha bajas 6...
2, 4, 6...
2 a la derecha, bajamos 6...
ahí tenemos los puntos, vamos a unirlos para
tener el trazo de la recta...
y...
ahí la tenemos.
Y como puedes ver, la solución del sistema
es el punto de intersección de las dos rectas,
es la pareja "x" y "y"
que cumplen con ambas ecuaciones.
Esta recta violeta, son los puntos de coordenadas
"x", "y" que cumplen con la ecuación,
"y" menos "x" igual a 5.
La recta verde comprende los puntos de coordenadas,
"x", "y", cumplen con la primera ecuación.
Ahora, el punto de coordenadas "x", "y" que
cumple con ambas ecuaciones,
es el punto de intersección.
Lo encontramos algebraicamente por
medio del método de sustitución,
"x" igual a 0 y "y" igual a 5...
"x" igual a 0, en el eje "y", "y" igual a  5.
Ahí está.